good morning you guys i want to say
happy fall but it's not fall yet so
tata to summer today bye-bye
it's been a long hot summer that's for
sure we're looking out you can see a
little bit of a brown haze out there but
overall we'll have good air quality
today 12 hours of daytime 12 hours of
nighttime that's the equinox we get that
in the spring and the summer and we're
looking at beautiful 60s this morning
this is the part that feels like fall
it's the afternoon that's going to feel
like summer we've got some low 60s out
there at red rock as well 50s up there
at kyle canyon so our first day of
autumn all right so we're still in
summertime
by mid-morning we'll be up to about 80
degrees the afternoon brings the heat
we'll be in those upper 90's above
normal temperatures and the evening will
cool off to some low 90's but that's
also when we'll start to see a little
bit of haze that's right more smoke will
be coming into our area tonight and into
thursday whenever we see the orange and
definitely the deeper colors that means
that there'll be more concentration of
some wildfire smoke around our area and
you can see that it's going to last
probably through tomorrow and maybe even
early into friday and those fires are
over here in central california the knp
complex has grown to more than 28 000
acres and the windy fire over 31 000
acres in the sierras over here and then
we're going to get a little bit of a
north breeze tomorrow and that's going
to pull that smoke right back into
southern nevada skies so that's what
we're looking for the increase in the
haze high pressure moving a little to
the east that's allowing the system back
into the northwest that system will drop
south of our area in the next couple of
days kind of meander south of us it will
stay extra warm upper 90s today again
the official arrival of autumn is 12 20
today during our lunch hour it's uh it's
when the summertime the sun the earth
leans into the sun for longer days in
the winter it leans away from the sun
for shorter days and spring and fall are
right in between equal day and equal
night so that's what we've got going
today hazy sun tomorrow haze will
probably last into friday and so will
the extra warm temperatures we should be
in the low 90s and instead we're looking
at extra warm days through the weekend
chance of rain if it comes will be south
of the valley for now
for the weekend so it shouldn't
interfere with all the racing going on
at the speedway nate oh yeah that could
be a problem